pauvre questions liées aux dettes ramzy
et puis je n'ai que ton détecteur de
maintenant pas du tout regardé à chaque
fois il a dit christian vers toi
revenons enfin y'a un mec qui est
derrière qui viennent les mecs au
détecteur nuage alors attention je vous
pose des questions il faut répondre par
oui ou par non
bram situe peut-être que tu es là tu
n'arrives pas à la règle c'est tout âge
nous ce sera la même taille attention je
fais je fais un petit est d'abord dans
une si vous dites la vérité
oui d'accord christian bonjour est ce
que ramzi est le plus grand acteur avec
qui tu n'es jamais tourné nue ou non
[Rires]
c'est vrai vous avez répondu donc oui
j'ai bien répondu non il n'était pas de
me sentir si vous faire un nom pour
faire rigoler quand va pas fuir on ne va
pas commencer à faire mais il faut oser
mission dont on se moque dans le micro
vieux micros les fier s'est passé
c'était bien de [ __ ] le bordel
royal il peut pas rester correct de ce
monde mais cela ne veut pas rester grec
de seconde à la batterie battini ramzi
est ce que christian clavier est la
personne que vous admirez le plus au
monde
mais bien sûr oui mais trop de micro
parce qu'il faut que wicked et où merci
oui ou alors si vous dites la vérité si
sévère c'est que vous dites il a menti
il a menti
si tu me déçois rôle d'acteur moi alors
mais attends moi j'ai dit la vérité
c'est sympa je vous pose une question
une autre question qui assure christian
mais oui que défilent tu appelles tu
vraiment cyril je voulais tester le oui
oui oui on l'appelle vraiment cyril oui
ok merci c'est vrai tu crois que je
m'appelle comment tu bernard cette
question y at il oui ou non une personne
dans ce métier
vous ne pouvez pas ça qui est oui
absolument
oui répondent que bormio pardon donc au
nom philippe tourteaux c'est un mec à
qui j'ai débuté je déteste il accroît
l'autre andouille
allons-y je traînais avec mais quand
bennie champlain de google défi qui
attend c'est qui ce tour toul ont donc
c'est vrai il part il a des mecs 36 pour
toi ramzy les noms il accomplit en
revanche il a compris ma petite amie est
ce que si on te proposer de tourner un
prochain film avec christian clavier
oui et sans être payé oui exactement
mais il l'a déjà fait la jeune interne
est mon cachet pour tourner sans sans
tourner tourner sans être payés rased
payer la question qu'a dit encore non
message accepterait pas moi qui tourne
sans être payés oui ou non il faut qu'il
paye pour donner avec moi
[Applaudissements]
c'est tout
sur les premières scènes qui a duré des
années collège m'a dit que ce soir a dit
oui ou non
de quoi donner gratuitement avec le à
christian et bien sûr combien sur moi
aussi je tourne avec lui dès la 8
enfants de cinq femmes différentes
je connais la personne je connais pas ça
qui me fait me dit que j'étais
consciente et agressions mais c'est moi
fabrice mais déjà fantasmé fonde avec
une de vos partenaires au cinéma
bah oui bon sur une de vos pas non plus
dur
si vous me promettez pokora je ne sais
pas pourquoi à chaque fois ils foutent
des musiques d'ascenseurs oui c'est la
musique là alors c'est toi qui a pu
mener la conférence s'est alors battu
pas ce détecteur de montsûrs les bains
on va voir vas-y est-ce que tu appuyé
non j'ai pas appuyer voilà oui monsieur
c'est caca dessus j'ai marqué dedans
prendre l'air d'accord j'ai compris je
me déconnecte la vente est désactivé
tout est désactivé ou du chocolat
non vous inquiétez pas c'est au fait
aller météo déjà tu appelles tu as déjà
fantasmer sur une canne partenaires le
principe de notre métier oui avec
davantage de toujours sur ses
partenaires un oui
[Musique]
christiane et honnête ramzy et puis je
n'ai que ton détecteur de mouvement pas
du tout regardé à chaque fois il a dit
christian verte warner n'ont en fait
rien mais qui est derrière qui fait
réellement faire le mec au détecteur de
métal est vraiment que j'ai les moyens
de payer quelqu'un oui en plus c'est
très très puissant le
je veux arrêter monsieur k éditions oui
on va où passer au détecteur est ce
qu'il ya quelqu'un qui manipulent
l'appareil derrière henry j non
ces cours duquel il m'a pas perdre son
boulot le mec c'est le pont du casse
tout est truqué
tout est bien cadré c'est très embêtant
s'il vous plaît calme tout comme quand
on voit à la télé comme g j pression est
ce que tu as déjà fantasmer sur une
personne que se tient
c'est du plastique oui tu as vu à la
télévision française me souviens qu'à la
télé bien joué oui mais dit oui oui
la société est ce que c'était que
maintenant on est leur moi comme des
chiens enfin non mais là ça va pas du
tout dans ces pénibles savez quoi
battu leur demande bah oui mais on l'a
compris dehors on va pas le refaire ma
tendre ballet nycb alors c'est sûr que
c'est une idée qu'on a compris qu'il
avait menti deux heures maintenant il va
le dire ça nous faisait zéro plus
tranquille coach ce monsieur quoi il ya
un doute je serai plus tranquille est ce
que tu penses que sherlock holmes a
vraiment existé
oui
donc ça s'est il dit la vérité mais
stable
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
donc il a dit la vérité est un con
[Musique]